[Music]
welcome to today's webcast
on harnessing the power of api data my
name is manoj gunty and i'm the product
marketing manager
for apigee api management platform at
google
also joining us today is adam brancato
from citrix a company that has been a
long time customer
of apigee and i will let adam introduce
himself in his own words
hey everyone my name is adam brancato i
am the senior manager of customer apps
over here at citrix basically our team
is responsible for a section of our web
apps
that deal with customer contacts
profiles single
sign-on authentication authorization
everything around
individuals in their company thanks adam
for joining us today
so before we begin the webcast i wanted
to quickly cover
a few housekeeping items what you see on
your slide
should resemble your webinar console on
the bottom
left there is a q a console where you
can post the questions
at any time during this webinar again
once again a quick reminder you don't
have to wait until the end of the
webcast to post your questions
feel free to post them at any time your
english webinar
and next to the q a console you will
also see a resources console
we will be making references to a lot of
resources during this webcast
and all the links to either download or
visit the pages should be available
in the resources console on your uh next
to the q a console
so we will begin this webcast by talking
a little bit about
the evolution of api programs how they
have transfer
from being agents of access to actually
being
agents of digital transformation we will
see
how that evolution has impacted or
created more pressures
on certain stakeholders within the
organization
and how api data can actually be
leveraged
to address some of those pain points of
these stakeholders and then i will pass
it on to
adam and he will walk us through the api
journey
of citrix uh he will talk a little bit
about some of the use cases that
they are trying to solve with apis um he
will also talk
a little bit about why they choose
apigee and how has been their experience
working with us
and then we will come to the most
interesting uh topic of this webinar
where adam will actually be
demoing the real-time dashboards and the
instances
of citrix and then when we come back we
will talk a little bit about
what are the different ways in which you
know api data can be leveraged within an
organization
and what other problems can we solve so
uh i thought
you know to explain or to talk a little
bit about the evolution of
apis instead of me going through some
slides
the best way to showcase that is to
actually give you
a show you a quick video of one of our
customers
accuweather who also has been partnering
with apigee for a very long time
so let's take a look at what activator
is doing with the apis
i became fascinated with the weather
when i was three years old when i fell
in love
with snow and by the time i was seven i
knew i wanted to be a weather forecaster
so accuweather i started in college as a
second year graduate student
and accuweather is now the largest
source of weather forecasts
and warnings in the world we've achieved
this
by having the greatest accuracy
[Music]
was founded 56 years ago really on pen
and paper
serving business customers over the last
10 to 15 years
really morph into a digital solution and
apis
basically power that entire
transformation the api
is a way of feeding the best weather
information
into other apps and integrating easily
however they want to use it we've been
using apogee for our api developer
portal for over 18 months
and since day one when we literally
started with xero developers
we've now branched out to over 50 000
developers out there in the community
a lot of people don't realize how many
products and services are out there in
the marketplace
using accuweather apis to power that
back end we serve
nearly 50 billion api requests per day
[Music]
apogee made it very simple for us to set
up self
sign up for potential clients it gives
us the ability to monetize our api
and also to offer free apis to people so
they can try it out
by having access to analytics we're able
to really get real-time information for
what our developers are doing what they
like what they don't like
allows us to make that quick judgment to
what we want to do moving forward in the
future as well as helping our developers
get better experiences out of our apis
the weather forecast is more important
than it's ever been the weather
can cause a flight to be cancelled rain
out a baseball game
it interacts with everything there are
millions of developers and
potential users around the world for
this api
they can take our data and our forecast
integrate it into whatever they're doing
and make it better
[Applause]
[Music]
so this is very interesting isn't it so
in the whole video you have not seen
anywhere mentions about access
about integration and all the stuff so
what we are talking today
is about creating experiences for
customers creating
digital transactions and actually
enabling digital transformation
through apis and we don't we are not
seeing this trend
just with accuweather or some of the
other customers but
in every day day-to-day conversations
that we are having with our customers
we are seeing that the topics of api
management
have evolved beyond just access and
integration
like enterprises today are exposing
their core business assets and if you
take the example of activeweather their
core business
asset is the weather data and they are
exposing them
to a fleet of developers and also
several businesses that are actually
using this weather data
through apis embedding them into their
business applications as well as
consumer applications
right and accuweather is actually
monetizing those apis
so it is essentially uh triggered
a new business channel for the
enterprise
leading to unlocking newer markets as
well as additional revenue streams for
the organization
so that that is how apis have you all
over the last few years
and when you think of you know apis
actually transforming businesses
what we also see is several customers or
several prospective customers
are actually still thinking of apis
as just a gateway but when you are doing
business critical stuff
i think it is very very important to
start thinking
of apis as not just one of
projects but to actually think of them
as business applications
right because you're not just you're not
just you know
providing access within your business
systems internally
but you are now actually reaching out to
your customers through
api and these products when you're
treating them as
a business application need to have a
full
life cycle management to be incorporated
but not just a simple gateway and
because the fact that you know a simple
gateway cannot give you all the security
levels
it cannot give you all the monitoring
capabilities and most importantly
it will not give you the capability to
make it easily consumable
for a wide range of developers so what
does that full lifecycle api management
platform
intake so it starts all the way from the
ability to
create a proxy design test all the way
until you know publishing it making sure
that it is secure
making sure that the right people have
the right access to the right apis
and also at the same time to do a lot of
analytics in the back end to analyze
essentially how are developers consuming
the apis
and are the apis available up and
running and how do i protect them
against abuse from bot and internal and
external up right
so what the evolution of apis and
treating
apis as a product means is that
now it is not just an api developer who
is
involved in the whole program so a wide
range of stakeholders now get
involved into this whole program all the
way from a product
or a program manager to a security or
i.t
ops person to the line of business
if i were the product or program manager
of a large api program then
i am very much interested in
understanding which apis are my
developers using what are the most
popular
api patterns how do i increase the
overall
developer engagement and for sure i will
have to
report the success of my program to my
senior management
and how do i very quickly and easily do
that and
from an i.t operations and security
perspective what happens is if your
mission critical or business critical
applications
are powered through apis let's take an
example
of a retail scenario where your
promotions or your payments
or your products catalog availability
reviews
everything is powered by a different api
and
imagine you are in a black friday and
cyber monday situation
and even a slight performance delay
of an api could lead to significant loss
in your revenue
right how do i as an operations person
make sure that my apis are always
available
they are always performing as expected
and at the same time
if something goes wrong how do i quickly
diagnose the root cause of this api
and bring it back to live as soon as
possible
and from a security and audit log
perspective
how do i make sure that all the
developers that are building these
amazing
apis adhere to the security policies of
my organization
as well as my industry and of course you
will not be able to scale up any of your
api programs without the buy-in and
investment
from the line of business and if i were
the vp of it the cio cto
or even the cfo some of the my biggest
concerns would be
what is the roi of the api program that
i have invested in
how do i measure it where should i
invest more
and which api should i actually which
api program should i actually retire
and what is the business impact or the
consumer impact of this whole
investment that i'm making right am i
able to reach out
to newer markets can i unlock new
revenue streams
or what else can i do with this
so what is happening on the other side
is as you build your build and scale
your api
programs there is you you actually start
to touch
each and every person in the api life
cycle
what we call an api life cycle is all
the way from the backend system that you
are
exposing to the api teams that are
building apis
and the developer that is using those
apis to build amazing apps
and the consumer who is actually using
the app
and indirectly using the api's attack
behind it
so across all these touch points as you
build and scale the programs
there is a lot of data that is being
collected
on the platform and this is one of the
other
big advantage that you get when compared
to an api
gateway right an api management platform
is essentially able to collect all this
data and be able to provide you with the
right
insights that will address some of the
problems that we discussed
in the earlier slide so apigee api
management platform
is a full life cycle ap management
platform that
has several layers including the runtime
layer the mediation
engine the api analytics piece
and also the developer ecosystem so if
we
look at the api analytics space there
apigee today provides several out of the
box
inbuilt uh reports that help all the
different personas that we talked about
it provides you
developer engagement metrics and api
program metrics
for the api operation for the api
product manager or program manager
persona
and it provides business metrics such as
the revenue report the customer churn
etc
for the line of business and it provides
you
operational metrics like the
availability the performance
the ability to quickly diagnose issues
linking
your alerts to the right playbook so
that you can take the appropriate
remedial actions
and also security reporting which is
about you know adherence to compliance
policies
and uh also analyzing the runtime
traffic
uh and at the same time looking at the
activity of
uh the users within your organization
whether they are accessing sensitive
data or not
so across all the three personas we do
provide
metrics and dashboards that address some
of the needs and what we will do
now is i will hand it over to adam who
will talk a little bit about
the trick what is their api journey and
how is citrix actually leveraging all
the data and the concepts that we talked
about
and some of the use cases or problems
that they are trying to solve internally
by leveraging this data over to you adam
so thank you news
so i'll start off i'll just kind of give
you guys a little bit of
background on citrix for anyone that's
not familiar with us
we're all about unifying apps and dating
secure workspaces
we deal a lot with virtualization of
desktops we have nest dealers that do
load balancing we have cloud platforms
where you can run
you know your entire desktop system
things like zen mobile that
uh manage your mobile devices
basically we believe uh work anywhere
on any device at any time so that's a
little bit about citrix obviously
head to citrix.com if you're interested
in more information
about the kind of stuff that we do here
at centre so
i'm going to kind of give you guys a bit
of a background on the citrix api
journey
we've been working with apogee just
about five years now
it started with a simple poc that me and
some other team members did
we were evaluating various api platforms
and now it's been five years we have
you know 40 production apis right now
on the right hand side you can see like
some of the highlights of the things we
do
we have sso apis we have ones that
people use to open support cases
asset management contacts you know all
these various things you see
here uh one cool one to point out is
you'll see there's a salesforce
spot listed right there one of the
really cool things we've kind of done
with salesforce is
salesforce themselves have a lot of
apis as well as old legacy services some
are you know rest services
some are soap services that you can
connect to as a sales force customer
however depending on their service it
depends on the authentication
there's a bit of back and forth and
things like that so we actually
wrote inside of apogee custom code
through apogee workflows to handle that
authentication
and then we sat apogee on top of that so
the consumers
really only have to worry about an api
key we send them
we handle the connections with
salesforce so that was
really cool that we're able to like do
all that in apogee
don't have to update salesforce and
consumers don't have to deal with that
it's behind the scenes our apis are
connecting
uh then internal and external consumers
we have obviously external consumers but
a lot of our traffic comes from our own
internal citrix teams
we're all over the world in several
different departments and we expose apis
to each other it's a great platform to
do it
finally it's simple um talk about some
of those things but it's really easy
platform to get started on for
developers and consumers
so here's i'm not going to go through
all these but here's a lot of the
reasons
why citrix chose apogee one of the
biggest ones is easy user and consumer
management
it's really easy to add new users give
people keys take them away and
like i don't have to do anything on my
back end it's really awesome
uh multiple formats are supported
like you know citrix we've been around
for
you know 30 years now so we have some
really new
services and then we have some legacy
ones that aren't
you know highly used that are in soap
and things like that
you know it's really easy to put a rest
front end on top of it and push it out
through apogee
and then there's some other ones in here
tracking uses which
i'm going to show you guys in a bit
reporting monitoring
it uses like a workflow uh ui
to do a lot of the configurations and
setup which is really cool and easy to
use
and then caching i'll actually show you
guys something
with caching after if anyone is not
familiar
with the caching apogee or i'm sorry
captioning feature of apogee
it's actually really cool because if you
have
an api call that is repeated often if
you turn the caching on
like that the call doesn't even go to
your back yet it just sends back the
same response like
if you have a call that gets you know
states for a country that doesn't have
to go to your back end every time so
you can cash that on the front end and
you know your back end doesn't get hit
if you're using platforms like azure
google cloud
to host your apis you know that could
definitely help reduce cost
all right so now let's talk about
harnessing the power of api data and
citrix so there's a couple different
ways
that we as citrix and especially myself
utilize a lot of the different pieces of
data that are exposed from apogee so the
first one
i'm going to talk about is the api
monitoring dashboard
which is been around for approximately i
would say it's relatively new in the
last year
um you know did you want to talk a bit
about that platform real quick the api
monitoring
sure adam so api monitoring uh is
essentially a feature that will address
the
ops persona of an enterprise business so
what api monitoring essentially provides
is
um in near real-time metrics that could
help
an operations person actually look at
the availability
of the api's business critical apis
it will give you an option to group some
of the
most important apis as a collection
and you can very closely monitor the
availability and the performance metrics
of those collections
and at the same time it has a very very
comprehensive
alerting capability uh on and very
very flexible alerting capability i must
say you can
have alerts triggered with various
dimensions
and various performance metrics
incorporated and
you can receive it there is options for
web codes you can get it on your
pagerduty
email slack and multiple channels and
when you get an alert through api
monitoring your diagnosis
process becomes very very simple when
you click on a button
and adam will actually walk you through
these steps in the demo but when you
actually click on the button you will
quickly be able to identify the root
cause
of the issue within one or two clicks
without even going to any other logging
tools like splunk
this is very very important for a lot of
customers of
ours because it significantly reduces
their mean time to diagnosis
and also the mean time to resolution one
primarily because the monitoring
platform being totally integrated
with apigee it gets a complete view of
the api value chain that we discussed
so across all these you will be able to
very quickly
very precisely pinpoint where the issue
has happened is it
because my backend is failing is it
because the deployment is not done
properly or
is it because of the front-end
application that this proxy
is actually free so we will go through a
live demo of it
but essentially uh you don't have to you
know
toggle between multiple screens you
don't have to do the pre-sessions you
don't have to
look into the logs and other other
screens to actually diagnose the root
cause of the problem
cool thanks so what you guys see here i
i highlighted a lot of stuff that menos
just mentioned
about like ad hoc monitoring of proxies
traffic error
latency timelines
uh for environments regions custom
alerts
so and i'll show you guys that in a few
minutes at the bottom here you see
there's a little screenshot i have of
like
it shows you kind of like what's hot
what's broken and
you know a few minutes i'll actually
show you what that looks like live
uh the next item we use here a lot is
something i call real time dashboard so
built into apogee like this is built in
all these dashboards and
little monitors i'm going to show you
guys later to show you current traffic
latency errors payload it's
very similar to the api monitoring
dashboard that kind of focuses in
on okay here's what the problem is now
the real-time dashboards kind of give
you some more in-depth stuff where you
can target specific things such as
like target performance so target
performance is
how your back end code is performing
where overall performance might look at
including
going through the apigee layer and your
back end
cache any custom code so this really
allows you to dive
deep into things in real time again and
i'll actually i'll show you guys that
and all the different things that come
there's a lot there to it
and i'll even show you an example of
like something we did a few weeks ago
where this came in really handy to show
up a problem we were seeing
finally custom reporting so
you can use custom reporting to do a lot
of different things
so some of the things like track
customer usage traffic drill down into
specifics
performance over long periods of time um
on the right hand side some of these
items i listed like quarter over quarter
comparison
target retirement uh targeting new
quarterly goals and new features
uh i'll kind of explain those a bit more
okay
so here's all these cool numbers and i'm
sure a lot of people at work
at their various companies all the time
you know everyone's like i want to see
reports on this
i want to see reports on that like show
me what to show me these numbers
one thing we try to stress here at
citrix is like okay
we have these numbers and these fancy
reports
like let's have action items make them
actionable
like it's great to show numbers but then
there should be action items
associated with them or else you know
you're just showing pretty charts
so i'll show you some of the stuff we've
done and like i'll show you some real
actual live reports
so then here's my guidelines stuff on
fire let's do some demos
uh going to share my screen
uh hopefully everybody can see my screen
all right if at any point something goes
out
or while i'm talking if you know the
screen shares a little behind let me
know and i'll you know
try to slow it down coordinated all
right so what you guys are seeing right
now is
uh this is our apogee this is our dev
instance which we use for our
non-production api
so i'm going to show you around there so
the first thing we're going to talk
about is that api monitoring item
so while that's loading
basically this is the dashboard i was
talking about
where immediately any time so right now
you'll see this uh for us this is
looking at our pre-prod environment
within our apogee environment instance
you can set up
different environments so pre-prod is
one of our testing environments so
if i'm if you know we get reports or
somebody wants to check on the health of
things as preventative measures because
we do have logging and things like that
like splunk like menos talks about but
this kind of
gives us okay what issues are we seeing
right now
so like up here in the top left you can
see all right you know
how much traffic we're getting a second
again there's not necessarily a ton
going on right now it's
testing so that's going to vary but then
we can see oh wow
like the account service for example the
accounting api in the us east
like that's bad right there's some
there's 91
error rate or something along those
lines so
you know someone would investigate these
obviously a lot of these numbers are
high
because this is a text environment so
people are testing things all the time
but i purposely chose this environment
because it's really easy to see like if
there's things broken
you can see them uh and then here's some
latency about like all right wow there's
you know that's taking 55 milliseconds
somebody might want to look into that so
these are all good tools to
you know if you want to see all of them
you know i click view all here and it
would show
all right what's the error rate for all
these different
uh apis and what's cool is it kind of
gives you this hotspot
item you can click on if something's
like bad or something like that
it shows me bam it'll show me current
trends for that
great there really there haven't been
any errors over uh
the last hour and you could play around
with these we could change the
environment you can see here so
this kind of gives you like a real-time
thing that you can fiddle with
uh there's this timeline feature which
is very similar
so this is if you want to go look at hot
spots all right so this tells me
some hot spots here of the errors
this is for currently for all the proxy
the different regions
but if you want you can target specific
regions
so for us at we have
us west coast and u.s east coast right
now for apogee those are where our two
regions are set up
uh so you can filter by that you can
filter by proxy as you can see we have a
lot
of different proxies here so you could
filter down on like one
was the account service we saw so you
can see wow look cool
uh there were 15 000 errors
so clearly something is wrong with that
service in the test environment
this is a great way to drill down so if
you do investigate
it's going to bring up another screen
which is really cool so what this tells
me is here's all the different errors
that these proxies are receiving so if i
go to
like the account for example uh
this is something where immediately okay
so this right here is getting a message
of
adapter flow error inside of the proxy
so
maybe something's configured wrong or
but
it's telling us exactly what's going on
we can filter this by the different
fault codes and policies
etc so this is again another tool
uh we'll go with too much more detail
here but kind of shows a little bit of
different items and you know there's a
lot more i kind of want to show you
so one of my favorite things is this
alert
so there's not a ton of alerts turned on
in this specific
environment because again it's a test
environment
you know it would trigger more often
than you would probably want to see
but what's really cool is to create a
custom alert
all you have to do is hit that button
you choose your environment
then you can choose your you know what
you want to monitor we could say latency
right and if i could say okay if the
latency is
greater than we could say you know like
1500
milliseconds for five minutes then we
would want it to
send an alert so and you can add a whole
lot more dimensions a whole lot more
condition data but
just do that real quick for you to show
you and then i could just put in here
my email address and then say how often
do i want to be bothered basically
so it would be 15 minutes you can do 30
minutes an hour et cetera
and
then i would of course i forgot uh then
you could set it up for a specific proxy
forgot to do that
uh i only i don't care what region do it
for all regions now i hit save
and of course we have to give it a name
account
latency alerts and you can set up
there's so many dimensions and factors
like there's no time to go through all
of them
but just to show you a quick example
when one of those gets triggered
like here's one i got earlier today i
purposely set
some low thresholds and broke stuff so
you guys could see that
okay cool like this is the email it sent
me at 12 15
today uh you know hey here's the org
here's the violation you click view
details if i actually click this link
it will take me right into this api
monitoring
dashboard and show me exactly what rules
i broke
show me the latency over this time
period uh
et cetera is all in this investigate tab
and again you can configure those so
many ways and you know you can get
alerts through email and there's other
methods as those told you about
so that's kind of a super quick overview
of api monitoring there's
definitely more to drill down into there
but you know we'd be here for hours
uh i will show you
something i mentioned earlier i called
out with these like
live dashboards as i call real time
so another one that we use
is especially this one we actually use
in
dev and production is
post deployment because as soon as we
deploy new versions of things
we can monitor things for like errors
right so let's say we just deployed this
account proxy
this shows me you know here's all the
errors over the last day again
something is wrong obviously because
look at all these errors
um you can see the response times here
and so this is telling me
over the last day you know the average
response time has been 135 milliseconds
uh and then you know down here is the
traffic per hour
so i will show you like real time for a
real
item that we ran into so i'm going to
change
to a different service something called
spf this is one of our
single sign-on apis that we use
i'm going to show you a specific time
frame
so we were working on a new feature
release
and we deployed
a new version of this api into
our test environment so as soon as that
happened
we got a few alerts and actually people
reached out to us too hey we're seeing
some latency
and this is perfect you can see so
oh my god let me see what's going on and
i went in and i looked at this
and you could tell exactly when we
deployed them
right because the average latency here
was like 200 milliseconds
and then all of a sudden about 10
o'clock eastern time
boom there's this big spike and now
we're looking at you know two
three thousand milliseconds and some
spikes over five thousand
so we're immediately able to see okay
that deployment today
definitely caused an issue again this is
a test environment but
it's good because you know we run unit
integration tests and some performance
things like that but okay now in the
actual environment there's an issue we
need to look at like
this is really easy to see and if i send
that out over like a 10-day period
go back here um you know we fixed this
problem
and you know there was a couple
iterations and we found out the root
cause of it
but you could definitely see once this
loads like
what are you know items were
uh may take a little bit of time so you
can see here okay this was when we
deployed the new one
we reverted back we tried again etc and
then you'll see after a few days
it's going to flat out but that's the
kind of stuff you can see immediately
like oh wow there's a new deployment
look at the spike in response time or
look at the spike in errors or something
along those lines
um finally i'll just show you or tell
you about there's this target
performance one
i won't go too much in the desk you know
that as we're uh
trying to show you a lot here but anyway
basically what you can do here is
this is all your back ends that are hit
and you could filter for this
based on ip addresses and things like
that to determine
if you have latency for specific
back-end ip addresses for example
how much traffic is going a different
target response time based on these
targets
again errors payload size etc
so this is if you want to specifically
target what
your backend is receiving so
the last one i'm going to show you is
custom reports
so custom reports
are basically outside of all those
traffic the other one that i will
mention sorry
error code analysis i didn't have time
to show you guys that but if you click
on that one
it's really cool it kind of shows you by
proxy all the errors the codes
and things like that kind of similar to
the hotspots we looked at
in the monitoring dashboard but anyway
here's some
reports that we have and i'm actually
going to
now we have to be really careful because
i'm going to switch to prod for a second
because there's better data and you know
you can see some cool stuff
so one thing i will show you or
tell you about is they they group these
things into what they call report jobs
so for example if i want to and i'm
going to kick one off just to show you
if i want to run something that's over
like a two-month period
three-month period or whatever it's not
going to sit there
and wait they actually have this new
feature that they launched
where it basically tells me boom
where in the report will let you know
when it's done
so that's pretty cool so while that's
running
i will show you two reports that i ran
earlier
just to kind of show you how we use some
of these reports
so all right so we have this one here
which is traffic
for
i'm gonna show two things here bear with
me
all right so wait for the other one to
load up but so what this is is this is
our traffic for
q2 um let me
i want to get these side by side
hopefully this will work
all right so
doing the best i can guys
all right so what we have here is q1
right
and we have account data service had
22 million calls that was all of q1
well if we come over here to
q2 the account service
has 140 million
that is a massive spike and this is the
type of
great stuff that we get from a report
because it's like okay and look if you
see here i can drill down
into different apps that are using these
and see that the cwc control center v2
went from 20 million
to 122 million and
i didn't have to do anything on the back
end i came right through apogee and
it's like okay so i need to figure out
what's going on
why do these guys have a hundred million
more calls is there
are they expecting this to be continued
and these types of things this will
drive like
what we do for the quarter all right if
this is going to be
the consistent level of traffic do we
need to
increase our servers on the back end
scale up in the cloud and things like
that
uh something else that we noticed real
quick i know i'm running short outside
uh we noticed some other groups had
big increases and i reached out to some
of them and so what's happening is
they're like oh yeah we have you know
other teams within our group that want
to use it and so
they we shared our api key well that's a
problem
so you really should not share your api
key so an initiative we're working on is
working with those groups
tell us your other team and we're
breaking down their api keys into
more specific api keys so we can more
accurately track
the usage of those specific teams so
like that's been really key for us
monitoring usage
worrying about do we have to scale to
support increased usage
quarter over quarter and things like
that tracking who's using keys should
they be using those keys
and you know things along those lines
like this one was a big one from q1 to
q2 because there's cost impacts there as
well
so uh that's my time for
showing the demos again there's like a
ton more to show but
you know i could kick off you know seven
reports
and if they're taking uh you know
too much time or something like that i
can come back and they'll let me know
and this one it won't show because it's
big so like you know i could export this
for example
and view it in excel and other platforms
i actually think no
about
um before before we go into questions i
just wanted to very quickly cover
um the security reporting feature and uh
before i talk about this i just want to
quickly remind
your audience if you have any questions
please don't wait until
the end of the webcast please do post
them um
as soon as you have and we will be able
to answer it in just about
five minutes last week we announced a
new feature
called api security reporting and what
this feature
essentially addresses is for the
security operations people
you can basically do three different
activities on this feature
one is you can very quickly review
which api proxies have been configured
with which policies across the entire
organization
and this is across environments across
regions and stuff like that
so if you are if you as a second person
would like to ensure that all of your
proxies have been configured
for example let's say spikerisk policy
this is the place where you can actually
quickly verify and cross it
and given the fact that you know
enterprises are now
exposing business critical and sensitive
information to
apis uh it is equally important for the
operations teams to also ensure that
the right people are have the right
access levels to
the sensitive data so data protection is
another
uh capability within this feature where
you can see who within your organization
is accessing the sensitive data has
there been any anomaly
in terms of their access patterns
and if yes then you can quickly contact
that person and understand
why he or she is actually trying to
access the secure
access you know secure data you can also
view
who within your organization is
exporting data out of the platform
through management api by the way i
forgot to mention that all the
capabilities
that you see in apigee including the
analytics the custom reporting
uh including the monitoring capabilities
can all
be done outside of apigee 2 through the
management
apis and if you would like to be part of
this beta program
and if you're already an enterprise
cloud customer of apigee
uh there is a lot of documentation out
there uh the feature is being currently
rolled out and if you are already a
customer you will see this feature
on your console probably by mid of next
week
and please use the documentation to uh
walk through this feature
so all the capabilities that we have
seen until now is
what is out of box available in apigee
edge
if this is all amazing stuff you can do
within apigee edge
think of all the different things that
you can do if you
could have the capability to take this
data out of
apigee and combine it with your
proprietary enterprise
data and derive some business and
operational insights
so apigee also provides the data export
capability where you can take the data
on a periodic basis
every day every byte of data into
your dcp console and you can use it with
your crm data
or erp data or any other proprietary
information
to derive some business benefits one of
our customer trust pilot is actually
trying to currently take the data out of
the system and they are trying to see
uh combine it with their crm data to see
who what categories of users are
actually
using what api products for them to
actually see
if there is an opportunity to monetize
these and if there is an opportunity
what are the different
rate plans and revenue models that they
can build out of it
so we kind of already worked on this uh
if there if you are already an apigee
edge enterprise customer
so please go to the documentation to get
started and understand how you can
harness the power of api data
and if you are not please go ahead and
sign up for a free trial
of edge with that uh
let's take a few questions so adam this
question is for you
the question is uh do you export any of
the data
outside of the platform and if yes how
are you using it
we do export some of the data those
couple ways a lot of these reports
can be exported out of apogee into
things like
excel and then we actually also one
thing that wasn't really talked about
much is
a lot of what you can do in apogee you
can
like through the ui you can use or i'm
sorry
access through api so we actually pull
some of the apigee data through apis
into our metrics reporting
to find out like we have like summaries
we show about
you know how our apps are being used and
we pull traffic data usage data
into some of our quarterly stats
monitoring and presentations we sent
other people
and then we also pull it into some of
our bi systems
so we can gauge how much items are being
used so
one thing we've used some of the traffic
reporting for is retiring old services
or api
so we actually are moving to a v2 of one
of our apis and it makes it really easy
to track
who are people still using it who they
are and contacting them to encourage
them to migrate
okay perfect so we have one more
question on
um where these capabilities are
available
uh is it also available on opdk and
hybrid so
i think it's a great question and i
think i should take some time to clarify
this
all the capabilities like the custom
reporting the monitoring security
reporting that you see on apigee
platform
is available to our enterprise cloud
customers
only and uh this will also be very soon
slowly roll out into the hybrid model
that we
are going ga towards the end of this
year um
but other than that opdk these these
capabilities are not available
you can use your own proprietary bi
tools to extract this data
and actually build some insights into it
all right i think we are almost to the
end of the time this is all the
questions
that we can take today uh if you have
any more questions please feel free
to bring us online and we will be more
than happy to answer them
that's all for today have a nice rest of
it cool thanks thanks everyone
thank you adam
you